this is what happens when a wildfire
rips through
in france a tourist haven
now hell
bikes lean melted and mangled abandoned
by holidaymakers as they fled the flames
which devoured five campsites
you can see here just how hot the fire
was the walls of this building have
totally
bubbled up inside just twisted metals
the skeleton remains of what was a
tourist hotspot
so much has been lost here and it's
still not safe
leaking gas can be seen openly burning
adding to this already monumental
challenge
but for french fire crews there is no
escape
day after day they return to the battle
we must keep the the the fight
all the people
because we must we must uh stop this
fire
there is no respite for evacuees either
families forced to flee their houses
sabrina and her baby catalina got a call
in the night
told leave now the fire is coming
they still don't know if it took their
home
joseph
okay
but they have no choice there's no way
of knowing when the fires will finally
be beaten
or what will be left when they are
siobhan robbins sky news south west
france